so the motivation for this talk of the
work I wanted to talk about is trying to
understand these things called galas
uniformity norms and functions that have
not too small values for the gals
uniformity norms so let me first write
down what the gals uniformity norm is
just say on z mod N and then talk a
little bit about why it's important so
suppose that F is a function from Z mile
n to the complex numbers then I'll just
give you the definition to begin with
the case so the order K goes uniformity
non is the following expression so it's
quite complicated
well
this right so what's going on so first
really I want to focus on this part this
is some kind of multiplicative analog of
a differencing operator you have a
function on zero then you rotate it by
this fixed element you and then
multiplied by its conjugate so I'm
multiplying by a conjugate rather than
an inverse but this is some kind of
multiplicative differencing operator and
so to define the norm I average overall
base points n and then over all K tuples
of possible differencing parameters and
for all of those I form this expression
which is the composition of these k
differencing operators applied to F and
then I averaged over all the parameters
there's the averaging and then I have to
take a 2 to the K throught to make this
homogeneous of order well and then it's
a result which over and show you that
this is actually a setting on this is
it's also it's a norm I think of K is at
least one all right from 0 to norm k is
at least two
okay so right now this is just a
mysterious formula the reason this is
important is that it appears as a tool
is the first reason it's important is
that it appears as a tool in gow as
proof of some radius theorem which as
many of you know is the proof that gives
much the best bounds so I only want to
talk about is just briefly remind you
why it appears in that proof and what
role it plays and having said that it'll
be clear audit is we want to know about
this norm and in particular what
functions take certain values for this
norm and then I can explain what is the
problem that actually motivates the real
subject of the talk so the reason this
comes up in Gauss proof of some radius
theorem is that if you have a subset a
well actually let me say something else
first so I'm going to make another
definition and then i'll talk about
summaries there so related to this is
another quantity which now depends on K
functions from 0-10 to the complex
numbers i'm going to write this lambda
and what this is this is an average over
all arithmetic progressions in zi ma 10
so i'll be averaging over the base
points and the common differences of the
product of the values of these functions
at the points of that progression
okay this is just some other definition
at this point this is a multi linear
form in these k functions so if you fix
all but capable but one of them then
it's linear in that one and the reason
this quantity comes up in studying some
register them is that if you have a
subset I've seen what n and you apply
the form lambda 2 K copies of the
indicator function of that subset then
what happens is that this product
expression is either 0 or 1 and it's one
if and only if all of these points are
in the set so this is just counting what
fraction of all the K arithmetic
progressions in the world lie inside to
set the proportion of K aps lying in a
and so galas proven really implicitly
all of the process Emery's theorem
actually show you that if a has a fixed
positive density delta then this
quantity can be bounded below by some
positive see of delta since for very
large n a vanishingly small fraction of
all the KA peas in the world are
degenerate they have so all the almost
all of them have K distinct terms once
you know that this has a positive lower
bound you know that for large n you've
found some care at operations okay so
that's what this has to do with some
radius theorem it's natural to try and
estimate this rather than look for
particular progressions because this
average quantity behaves more smoothly
and then the norms come up as a means of
controlling the values of this multi
linear form so that control is by virtue
of I guess I can go here something
called the Gala's koshish Watson policy
so this says that if you have your k
functions from zero then to the complex
numbers then you can pick one of them so
you can pick some I between 1 and K and
then you can control the value of this
multi linear form the absolute value
using the you I think it's k minus 1
norm of your chosen function and the 0
infinity norms of the others
so it's obvious it's very easy so you
can control this just buy the products
of all the other finish enormous but
actually you can choose one of them and
replace it with this uniformity norm and
that's actually a lot better because
this is often much smaller okay so
that's the girls koshish watsonville t
this is proved by an iterated appeal I
think it to cosi Schwarz inequality K
times K minus 1 times I guess so if
we're counting applications of kosher
shots there's k minus 1 right there and
this means that for many sets you can
say very quickly that they contain a lot
of care as much of regressions because
if you have a set whose indicator
function is close to its expectation in
the UK minus 1 norm so i'm going to
write delta for just the density of the
set hey so cardinality of a over N then
when you look at this multi linear
reform apply to the indicator function
of a I can swap out the first indicator
function for the constant Delta and
incur a small error because this
difference is small and all the
functions are uniformly bounded by one
so this is approximately landed with a
delta and an indicator function and then
I could do the same for the second entry
and so on now after doing this K times
again the density I really care about is
roughly lambda of several copies of the
constant function Delta which is Delta
to the K so provided this is less than
Delta to the K over K I get my positive
proportion of care at my progressions so
that tells you that for those sets which
satisfy this inequality you already know
there are many care at mighty
progressions contained inside them and
for example you can check very easily
you can check directly but you can also
check using these norms that a random
set is very very likely to satisfy these
estimates so a random set has a very
highly within the randomness there's
very high concentration in the number of
charismatic progressions and it's
roughly this proportion
so in girls prefer some radius theorem
the first step is to introduce these
norms and give this very simple
deduction and then the hard work is in
treating the opposite case so if you've
heard about the division somehow
philosophically between the structured
and random cases improves our sim radius
theorem this tells you what the random
case means it means sets that satisfy
this inequality and then instructed case
which is the bulk of the work is to try
to understand what it tells you about a
if this inequality is violated okay so
just write something for main work for
proving some ready is to understand the
structure whatever it means of those
well I really care about those sets but
in general it makes sense to study the
larger class of functions those
functions F such that this guy was
uniformity no is not too small episode
it's bigger than some threshold that you
chose to say eater also so it makes
sense to enlarge the class of objects
you look at two functions but I don't
want to allow functions for which this
is large because of having some small
sub very tall narrow spike so I know two
different functions to the unit disk
okay so this this is often called the
inverse problem for the Gala's norms it
asks for some structural description of
the functions to satisfy this and if you
get a good enough description then the
idea is that having handled the case of
random sets you can use that structure
to prove that the sets in the remaining
case must also contain some positive
proportion of arithmetic progressions
for some different reasons for some
structure reason and that's how Gao is
proof and variant more recent variants
of it go of summaries theorem so
implicitly in goers work there is an
answer to this inverse problem so garras
gives one answer and then more recently
there's been a more technically
sophisticated and precise precise answer
given in terms of these objects called
nil sequences by greentown Seagram
and secondly I won't go too much into
exactly what they showed but we actually
do know fairly well what the right
answer to this question is in this one
dimensional settings technically quite
complicated but we do have a very good
description so what I want to talk about
haven't gotten anything right what I
want to talk about is what happens if
you try and mimic this approach in the
case of the high dimensional summer 80
theorem so let me formulate this the way
I want so now you fix some positive
Delta and you also fix a finite subset
of ZD then if n is large enough
depending on Delta and also on the size
of this fly they said and you have a
subset now of Z mod n to the d whose
density is at least Delta then a must
contain some translated and dilated copy
of this F where a read f mod n and also
this has to be non degenerate so then
you must be able to find such a
translate and dilate so that no two
distinct points of air for identified so
the one-dimensional severities theorem
is just this theorem I'm sorry this also
depends on d ok so the one-dimensional
separate athira ms just this theorem
where d equals 1 and f is a fixed k
arithmetic progression say from 0 to k
minus 1 and then this becomes a general
athletic progression so this has various
proofs like the original sin ready i'm
using a gothic theory using hyper graph
theory but there's no analog of the
Gala's approach that's been completed in
this setting except from one special
case Judas grade off which I should
mention but won't tell you too much
about
there is a bound that depends on size of
F yes and there's actually with a little
bit of playing there are sort of Freddie
fixed size there are universal f's so
you get ya you get it from that so what
I want to do is try and tell you what
happens if you try to mimic gals
approach in this setting so again it's
easy to write down the relevant locked
in the near fall so suppose F has size K
what should do better than that suppose
F is the set V 1 up to VK then the
relevant multi linear form is now an
average over all translates and dilate
of f of the product of the values of
these functions at the corresponding
points of that translating dilate of F
so so fastly but this is the right
quantity to study now you want an analog
of the cows koshi schwartz in a protein
you get that to says that this this
value lander is bounded by the product
over the j is not equal to your chosen I
or the 0 infinity norm x something like
a uniformity norm but now it's not the
most simple analog in higher dimensions
of the uniformity is Norman we had
before now it's something that has to
remember the directions of these vectors
v1 up through VK and actually what
happens is that the uniformity norm you
have to apply to the I function depends
on the differences between VI and the
other vectors v i- VK
not the I minus so this is some new
Gower's known to New uniformity norm
that depends on the choice of certain
directions now let me tell you what it
is
so to some choice of direction say you
one up to UK this is again going to be
an average over base points in the whole
group and then over some differencing
parameters but now these will only run
over Z more n and that's because inside
the expression that we average we're
only allowed to apply the differences in
the directions given by the you is so
along multiples of those you eyes okay
and then again there's a 2 x k outside
and i guess there's an end to the minus
t minus K okay so this is the higher
dimensional Gaussian for this is the
direction of gals uniformity know and
this is where this approach gets stuck
because we don't have a good inverse
theory for these norms even in the
one-dimensional case this is this seems
to be more than what you know yeah but
not very much and when one dimension is
not very much more pick up well okay in
wonderment there are some arithmetic
issues but in one dimension if for
example you're in Z mod a large prime
then all of these will just run over the
whole group so it's the same it's really
the issue is really that you might have
these one-dimensional directions in a
higher dimensional group and your
constraint to difference along those ok
so again there are some other special
cases what we do have a good inverse
theorem for this and I sort of morally
feel like I should tell you more about
them but I'm going to hide that because
it is true that in general we do not
have an adequate inverse theory for
these norms to use an ax proof of
similarities theorem or for anything
else really so what I want to talk about
today is some work related to this
question but only to a very basic toy
instance of this question so I certainly
can't give you any kind of inverse
theory for these norms in general what I
want to ask instead is what does it mean
if a function actually takes this
extremal value for these norms
in verses sort of I'll tell you what it
is in a little while sort of conjecture
that I'm not sure I believe so it's not
my conjecture for sure but anyway we'll
come back to that ok so the toy problem
or maybe better to say the extremal
problem is to describe those functions F
and again I'm going to let them go
anywhere to the unit disk but I want to
rule out functions with spikes that's
somehow not the phenomenon of interest
for which this quantity is actually
maximized rather than just somewhat
large so let's quickly think what that
means if you look at this is an average
of values that are all given by products
of values of F inside here I every time
I apply differencing operator I take two
different values of my function to
multiply them so this is actually a
product of two to the K values of F in
different places the only way that the
best thing this could do is if these all
line up somewhere on the unit circle
because this is a norm it had better be
at the point 1 so the maximum possible
value is 1 and this happens only if this
expression inside the average is
actually identically equal to one for
all nh-1 through HK so the problem want
to talk about is describing those
functions F that satisfy this equation
so this is now an algebraic problem
hopefully it's simpler than the full
inverse problem so before i go into what
we can say about this let me at least
give a little more motivation for
studying this very basic special case of
the full problem firstly if you're going
to solve this you'd better be able to
say something about this clearly if you
can't solve this but then another way if
you can't solve this this is going to be
impossible
what you want a different table dancer
he just wants correlation something yeah
so even though even that would be some
information here you must learn
something about these functions so
that's not necessarily true we're going
to show that if you've got the cows
numbers at least Delta that it's
something to do with one of these 100
sets yeah okay so that's actually my
next point that's my next point okay
very good if you if you choose as I do
to see those changing the subject
country to what men choose is um then
the next reason to care about this
problem is that what happens in one
dimension at least according to galas
approach is that if you have a function
on Z mod n whose gals and always
somewhat large his conclusion is that
you can find inside Z mod n many long
arcs with arithmetic progressions inside
them length something I think it's n to
some epsilon where epsilon depends on
the other parameters such that on these
arcs your function correlates with an
exact solution and I'll tell you what
the exact solutions are in a little
while so in the one-dimensional setting
you find that the gem one version of the
general investor the original version do
two hours is that a function whose
uniformity arm is somewhat large has
correlations on many large arithmetic
pieces of the group with exact solutions
you would like that to be true in high
dimensions as well perhaps but once you
have this you still need to know what
the exact solutions are to use that
information improving summaries theorem
so we'd better solve this problem as
well if we want to use this in attacking
the multi-dimensional summer ad theorem
the third reason for studying this
question is it turns out there's
actually quite a lot of very very varied
solutions here and they're quite pretty
in their own right so hopefully I'll be
able to show you that at least by the
end of the top okay
so that's the algebraic question I want
to talk about I'm going to generalize it
a little bit yes yes except thank you
for saying that so given that this takes
values in the unit disk in order for
this to hold everywhere it better
actually take values on the unit circle
if it goes inside anywhere than this
product you're right I beg you upon yes
yes I misunderstood you yes that's right
yes sir 10 to the d okay but it did
remind me of something I need to say
which is that for this to equal one F
must actually take values on the unit
circle because if it goes inside
anywhere this product can't go back out
so f actually goes from zero den to the
D to the unit circle okay so I want to
generalize the set in just a little bit
and again I'll tell you why in a moment
I want to work on an arbitrary compact
abelian group so you can think of a
finite abelian group like zine will
enter the D or you can think of a
d-dimensional torus or an
infinite-dimensional Torres as you like
and I'm going to imagine that I have a
collection of closed subgroups you went
up to UK and now I want to describe
those measurable functions f from Z to
the circle group which for me is the
real numbers mod the integers such that
the analog of this equation holds what
I'm going to do now is write this
equation additively and that's why I've
switched to our mod Z because it'll be
easier to write things additively from
now on so such that
whenever you pick some elements you one
of the first group in you two of the
second group and then apply what is now
an additive differencing operator so
this is f of Z translated minus F of Z
whenever you apply these additive
differencing operators at these chosen K
elements of the K groups you kill the
function that make sense so this is some
this is what I'm calling a partial
difference equation it's a very naive
discrete analogue of an order K linear
partial differential equation with
constant coefficients so the simplest
kind of higher-order PD you can think of
this is some difference equation analog
yes I should thank you very much yes yes
if I'm writing things additively so this
is now zero the problem is to describe
the measurable functions to do this
don't worry too much about the
measurability requirement as you know
that's something extremely weak it is
important for the theory that follows
but it's not a serious constraint in
what in what I'm going to tell you about
their reasons for making this
generalization firstly where there are
three three reasons firstly it somehow
clarifies a lot of what's going on
because all other what I want to say is
not special 20 10 to the D and it makes
sense to work in a more general context
secondly it also allows me to cover
other finite abelian groups such as
vector spaces over a finite field where
there are also versions of the
multi-dimensional some really theorem
that you would want to attack so it
covers all of those at once that second
reason is enough to motivate you to
study a general finite abelian group but
the third thing is that for some of the
theorems we can prove here now various
parameters that come out do not depend
on the group but the only way I know how
to prove that is by some limiting
compactness argument and when you run
that argument in the limiting problem
you get a group that's not find out you
get a torus or something so you really
want some compactness in the space of
problems which I won't go into in too
much detail to run those arguments okay
so that's the setting are going to work
in now and this is the problem I really
wanted to talk about pom-pom put okay
so now let me very quickly show you some
example solutions to an exam example
problems firstly the simplest case
somehow Odrick algebraically is when all
of the you is are equal to the whole of
Z and that corresponds to what we said
in the one-dimensional summer 80 theorem
where you have these directions in zero
down and you're assuming that they cover
the whole regime of it so now you have a
function from Z to the unit circle and
you're asking that whenever you form any
differencing operators of it k times you
kill the function and for any sensible
definition this is equivalent to f is a
polynomial of degree at most K minus 1
so in the case of say Z being Z mod n to
the Dior also you could ask this
question on cd-r I didn't say this very
well let me write that in a slightly
more precise way yeah so in case your 10
10 to the D or Z to the d this is saying
that if you difference your function
anywhere you like k times you kill it
that's a characterization of polynomial
T because I'm going into T I should say
that F equals say P more than one where
P is a polynomial degree at most K minus
1 and if you write these
multiplicatively you get something like
e to the 2 pi i times a polynomial and
this is what's often calls a phase
polynomial and these are the basic
objects that appear is the exact
solutions to this problem in Gaia's
approach so these are the things that
you get correlation with on those along
sub progressions in Z mod M okay so
that's what happens when the US are the
whole group exactly what polynomial
means does depend on Z so if you're
working in Z mod n then you can use your
naive definition as a sum of monomials
if you're working on the circle group
the continuous circle group then
actually there are no polynomials of
degree higher than one so there
fine functions and then it stops so it
does depend what group you're working on
but this is this is the answer for any
sensible interpretation a polynomial
it's that's one example let me show you
another extremely different example but
also very simple in general you could
just let F be a sum of functions f1 up
to FK where F I is you I invariant so
what that means is that inside the big
group Z F is constant on all the cosets
of the subgroup you I so then the i'th
differencing operator here kills the Sun
and fi so that composition kills all of
them it's not the very simple example
and having noticed that you can also
generalize these two classes of example
by choosing some sub collection of the
uis and using a function which behaves
as a suitable polynomial on every cosset
generated by that sub collection so let
me just write this
so you're looking at all possible sub
collections of the group's you went up
to UK say they're indexed by this subset
e then having chosen a subset e you form
the sum of those subgroups of Z so maybe
Z is we have 100 dimensional tourists
and you chose 74 dimensional sub
torres's and you add them together that
gives you a subgroup and then you ask
that fe be a polynomial of degree at
most the cardinality of e minus one on
every coast out of that subgroup and
then this will be annihilated by the
product of the differencing operators
just coming from that subgroup so each
of these is killed off by this smaller
differencing operator for this reason
and so the whole thing is killed make
sense okay so if you like me you play
with we play for a while and you come up
with these examples and then you play
for much longer and you don't see
anything else and you begin to think
that that's everything but it's not so
here is example for so let's see be the
three Taurus and let f of the three
coordinate be the following function
where I'm going to write it and then
tell you what it means so this is a
fractional part notation what this means
is I take an element of tea r mod Z and
I look at its representative in the half
interval from 0 to 1 so this is in 01 so
this sum is the sum of two real numbers
it's between 0 and 2 so the integer part
is either equal to 0 in which case the
whole expression is 0 or equal to 1 in
which case I take the value t3 so you
can draw a picture of this function here
is the 3 Taurus maybe we'll use a
different color what this function is
doing its cutting the three Taurus into
two pieces depending on the t1 and t2
coordinates so it cuts it into the piece
on this side of that diagonal plane and
that side of the diagonal play on this
side its 0 and on that site it agrees
with the third coordinate
so it still has some polynomial flavor
but it has this cut in the middle which
is very much not a polynomial flee okay
so I'm here to tell you that this is
killed where you one is the subgroup
given by the first coordinate you too is
the subgroup given by the elements t
comma minus T comma 0 and u 3 is the
subgroup 0 t minus T and U for is the
subgroup given by the last coordinate so
you can go and check that if you feel
like it if you difference by any
elements of these groups you get zero
okay so that's that's a fun fact I
should also mention this didn't just
come out of the Hat I didn't just wake
up one day and realize that this was a
solution this function actually means
something in group co homology and the
fact that it satisfies this equation is
a consequence of a very important
equation in group co homology that this
function satisfies which i'm not going
to go into a too much detail so all you
dimension wonder this function and
pretty normal right yeah so it's a funny
thing in dimension one in the classical
theory these fractional polynomials come
up in the solution of the full inverse
problem but not the exact problem no but
here this is really a solution to the
exact problem and it really needs this
integer part and there haven't proved
that it really needs it but it does i'll
tell you what i mean by that in a little
while okay so there are these more
exotic solutions and actually once you
know that you get these solutions coming
from group co homology you can produce
more and more complicated examples you
can actually produce huge families are
very funny looking examples but they do
all involve these integer and fractional
parts somehow it's a week calvin moore's
measurable group technology for locally
compact groups and publish modules it's
you know there's 100 group colleges out
there there's a right one gives you this
ask me after i can tell you a lot more
about it but for now this is there is
one it works for groups like the circle
into the circle and this is what you get
okay
so there are these more exotic solutions
and at this point my feeling is that you
can't hope for really complete answer to
this question the way we have in one
dimension you can't hope for an answer
that just says take a sum of monomials
but you can still say quite a lot about
the solutions so what I want to do now
is tell you some things that we can
prove about solutions to this problem so
some general results so first let me set
up some notation i'm going to write f of
z 2 t for the group of all functions
from the all measurable functions from z
to t and as usual I will now myself to
identify them up to equality almost
everywhere that doesn't matter at all
for finite groups so having done that
this carries a natural topology you can
see it as for an LP topology or so or
the topology of convergence in
probability and then provided Z is
reasonably nice so provided Z is not
enormous in some set theoretic sense
this is a Polish group that means
there's a complete separable metric
generating its topology so it's
something like a separable Banach space
except it's not about our space because
these are not functions into a field
their functions into the circle but
somehow from a soft general topology
point of view it's something like a
Banach space okay it is a group and more
of a Z act on it just by translating the
argument of the function so it's
actually a Polish Z module and inside
this I want to pull out a collection of
sub modules i'm going to write them m.e
these are the functions which are
annihilated by the differencing operator
that just uses the subgroups index by E
so let me write it instead is give the
subset of name set I one up to I l these
are the functions that are annihilated
by the differencing operator i get if i
only use the subgroups you I one up to
you I
so these are all contained in this big
group f you can easily show they're
closed for the topology of convergence
in probability and also if you rotate a
solution to this equation then it's
still a solution so these are closed sub
modules okay also if you enlarge the
subgroup so the subset that means you
are applying more differencing operators
here so any solution to this equation
also satisfies this equation so as he
gets larger this module also gets larger
so that much is just notation so now
having written that let me very quickly
tell you what is the most naive thing to
do if you want to understand a solution
to the full partial difference equation
so an element of M sub sub script the
whole set one up to K so suppose F is in
here we don't know what it is when you
stare at this for a while there's really
only one thing to do which is to pick
one of the subgroups a UK apply a
differencing operator and now look at
what you have this for each little you
in UK is an element of a smaller module
because now this is killed off by the
differencing operators that don't use UK
I've already used it so I don't use it
again so this goes into M subscript k
minus 1 so what I'd really obtained here
is a map from UK to the module MK minus
1 ok so you have this unknown function
that satisfies the author kay equation
from it you contain a map from UK two
functions that satisfy the order K minus
1 equation in order for this to be
useful what you would like is to be able
to say something about what maps you get
out here our priority before you know
the structure of F or the full module so
an arbitrary map is an arbitrary map but
this is not an arbitrary map this map
satisfies one very important relation so
let me call this G sub you
it satisfies the one co cycle equation
that means G sub U of Z plus G sub P of
Z minus u is equal to G sub U plus V of
Z and that's because if you simply write
this out as differences of F 2 of the
terms cancel and leave you with the
right hand side so it's very simple so
this G has given you a map from UK into
this smaller module which we're assuming
we already understand as part of some
inductive hypothesis which satisfies
this equation so what you would like
ideally is to be able to say what all
the maps are satisfying this equation
into MK minus 1 before you know anything
about MK and then you would have the
kind of information that would give you
another cycle of the induction so the
problem of doing this is precisely a
problem in group co homology that's what
group cosmology studies or at least
degree one group co homology studies
maps from a group like UK into this
module that satisfy this equation so
this is the one co cycle equation so to
use this you want to study I'm just
going to write down its name and group
homology if you don't haven't seen this
before don't worry about it some
algebraic object which describes up to
some natural equivalence all the maps
from UK into this module that satisfy
this equation this is called h1 this is
the first group in group technology so
the nice thing is that if you know
enough about group car mods you can
compute this provided you know
abstractly what the module MK minus one
is I'm telling you this because it leads
to a very important shift in our point
of view instead of studying individual
solutions I'm first going to try and
understand the structure of the whole
module as an abstract group having done
that I can work out what this is and
hopefully get the structure of MK from
this
so change of emphasis to studying the
whole module okay so let me tell you the
first main theorem about these modules
and then I'll just mention that you can
actually get quite a lot about
individual solutions from this as well
so i'll write the theorem in a moment
what i want to bring up now is that as
mentioned here if you have a solution to
a simpler equation it's also a solution
to the more complicated equation so a
natural first question to ask about the
module of all the solutions is to ask
for a description of them modulo the
simpler ones so let's say that elements
of the sum of all the simpler problems
are degenerate solutions so these are
the functions that satisfy the full
equation because they can be written as
a sum of things that satisfy strictly
simpler equations so the first thing I
want to do is understand the structure
of M sub K modulo this ok so here is the
theorem and this is the start of a
larger picture that it probably won't
give you in full subject to some
condition it's very simple condition
that I will come back to in a moment
this quotient is discrete
and moreover I'll write this in there
talk about it it's separation is bounded
only in terms of K okay let me just go
over this firstly i'm going to assume
this somehow non degeneracy condition on
the problem that the U is together spend
the whole of Z that's not true then you
can just choosing a separate solution on
every Co set of this sum and produce a
solution on the whole of Z so the
general picture is just this picture on
each co set of the sum of the UI's
separately so you can easily reduce to
this case having done so what you find
is that this is if I'm saying this is a
case at least two once k is at least two
all the solutions take the form of some
element of a discrete list of well
separated solutions clough degenerate
ones so as a discrete and actually if Z
is a reasonable group this is what has
to be countable there's a countable list
of well separated solutions to this
problem and everybody is one of those
plus a degenerate solution moreover yes
but so choose your favorite metric
convergence of anything that gives you
convergence in probability this will be
true I mean the constant will be
different but just choose something that
gives you convergence in probability so
choose l1 this nada vets not the whole
band of space are not real valued it's
just as a circle there's no functions
with spikes yes I choose your favorite
metric giving convergence in probability
then you can choose this countable list
so that even if you modify the entries
by generate solutions whatever you do
modular degenerate solutions they all
have to stay far apart and how far apart
they are doesn't depend on the group's Z
or you won or you too it only depends on
how many of them there are so this is
non-trivial even for finite groups like
the whole thing is non-trivial even for
finite groups but this is the surprising
part and that's where I needed some
compactness argument having said this I
also want to tell you without writing
anything that the proof of this
implicitly gives you an algorithm for
calculating this exponent it's a very
very long this question it's a very long
impractical algorithm but the proof of
this is that you have if it's in
principle some procedure for computing
what this is and then you can show that
Carrie's qualitative properties along
with it so you feed in ingredients that
satisfy some version of these hypotheses
and what you get out has to satisfy them
to this is a very standard thing in
homological algebra that you write down
some enormously complicated
calculational procedure that you would
never actually run but you show that it
preserves the qualitative features you
care about so that's how you get this
and then there's that this is actually
just the top case of more complicated
conjecture that I guess I won't show you
let me just finish by mentioning a
couple of other things that you can get
from the same algorithm so firstly once
you know this discreteness you can solve
not only the one hundred percent
extremal case of the gars inverse
problem but also the ninety-nine percent
case so still and be so for every for
every epsilon and k there is some eater
such that if you have a function g from
z mod n to the d to a unit disk and this
gals uniformity norm is bigger than 1
minus eater so it's very very close to
maximal then it's because g is actually
within epsilon say in the l1 norm of an
exact solution so there's a stability
result and once you cook this correctly
you see this follows fairly easily from
this discreteness not trivial so this is
just a qualitative assertion about these
modules but the proof of this also gives
you an algorithm that in concrete cases
you can use to compute exactly what the
quotient is and compute a list of
Representatives you simply won the exact
exactly no no I can't and I'm sure that
it's not possible I mean the world of
them is enormous it's a very very long
algorithm with many steps that produces
eventually some funny list but it's it's
not as simple as in one dimension I
don't think there's a sink way of
writing it let me tell you one final
thing I've gone over time but this will
be very quick the other another
qualitative feature that you can carry
forward when you run this this algorithm
is that you can choose for this list of
basic representatives so in theorem a
choose list of Representatives which are
generalized polynomials so we destroy
your picture to say what that means if
you're imagine on a torus so imagine
you're on a torus a generalized
polynomial is a function that cuts the
tourists into finitely many polyhedral
pieces and on each of those pieces is
given by some simple polynomial
expression this is what happens in that
last example I showed you it cut the
three tourists into two pieces and gave
you something linear you can find
examples that cut them into more pieces
and give you higher order functions on
the pieces that feature is irremovable
but you can always find functions that
have this algebraic form they're not
arbitrary measurable functions and then
there's some very messy quantitative
version of this yes no really polyhedral
yes this is a 2 Taurus
so I ok ok so I'm sorry went over time
but that's part of the story thank you
very much yeah so the conjecture is
actually what been referred to that the
full inverse story is that if a function
has not too small uniformity lon then
you can find these big pieces of Z
modern to the D on which it correlates
with an exact solution so it correlates
with somebody in here um I'm very
agnostic about whether that's true or
maybe I'm a little bit skeptical but
that's their thing as the conjecture
unless you want to add to that I they
say well suppose that is true and
suppose within what you've just told you
make some other sort of reasonable
conjectures is there a program that
generalizing what's trade-off in two
arbitrary dimensions yes but rather not
try and describe it directly yes 0th
what do people so straight off ok
straight up scrapes grade off has given
a new proof of the case of the
two-dimensional some reason what you
look for these d's up right I source of
these corners and for that he gets some
inverse theorem for a particular galas
norm and he can extract enough
information from it to get this improved
bound and then he I think he can also do
the case of a configuration where you
have an L so you have a point and a base
button then two points above it
something like this but for example a
square we don't have improved bounds for
the multi-dimensional some really
sitting where you're looking for a
square so that will be the next next
case to try if you could prove this full
version of the inverse theorem using
these functions then that would yes give
you a program for attacking that problem
its success of course depends on the
bounce and I haven't said anything about
balance the bounds here already are
pretty tell me know in the bad so it
seems to be very difficult to classify
these
some functions in these generalized
current all right but you can sort of do
that somehow enough with these
conjectures yeah because I think this
kind of qualitative feature if you can
control the complexity of this
representation you can't write down a
list of all the polyhedra you might need
or all the pieces you might need but if
you know this kind of regularity with
good enough pounds that should be enough
yeah yep so just to be clear he didnae
and disk injection and there's something
once and for like that's I mean the one
sensibility was obviously and having a
structure which correlated like with one
of those get it then then this wood is
willing to try good rounds no no no this
would give you a program to go look for
good bounce right getting those bounds
will depend on the quality of the bounce
in that inverse theorem and I've no idea
what that would be yes also just one of
the mat looks that they might go to view
this question of understanding the
extreme function is as exciting if not
even more exciting than just pushing the
bounds for hi I'm really glad you think
that because I think that to work
alright nervous about saying that to a
computer its audience I agree but on the
other hand I am that class is still even
gawas gnome is not so sacred so maybe
the other gnomes especially in high
dimension even in one dimension that
that can play a similar or even better
over yes I don't think you're going to
avoid well okay so let me just say
something very briefly about this um I
don't think you're going to avoid having
to solve some problem like this yeah and
I'm saying that partly because you can
ask a related question which doesn't
involve the extra misers of the GAO's
norms where you can instead you can just
ask for tuples of functions f1 up to FK
on say Z mod end unit circle for which
the expression the product that you care
about is identically equal
one and if you have fun if you have some
couple of functions to satisfy this then
taking level sets of those you can you
can produce a very anomalous set from
the point of view of the
multi-dimensional some ready theorem and
describing these tuples is actually a
special case the same methods give you a
full description here but not a full
inscription they give you an analogous
description here so I think you can't
you know I could've given the whole talk
about this problem and all the
conclusions are qualitatively the same
so this you're saying and use all these
things everything you get from here food
yeah just to study chuckles of functions
whose sum has some vanishing property
the whole story is analogous